we're here inaugurating these new
studios and you know I just cannot think
of a better way to say gee these are the
end of our three days and for you guys
to do this for us
I really am so appreciative I really
just think it's great and I know the
audience is flipping out that you're
here so thank you very much thanks Dan
to a spectacular week thank you to whine
things up you've agreed to do wake me up
when September ends and this and I'm
amazed by the story behind this song you
lost your father when you were 10 Billy
right that's right I guess your mother
or somebody said to you hey come out of
your room you were you were devastated
that you'd lost your father and you just
said wake me up when September ends and
and to me not only is that a profound
line but the fact that you held on to it
for years and years later remember that
did you write that down or is that
something that just stayed with you that
just stayed with me it just kind of
month of September always kind of being
that anniversary that sort of I don't
know it's just kind of a bummer but I
think you know it's weird because like
when things happen and when you're like
that when you're that young it's almost
like you kind of it's like life starts
at like years hero or something like
that again so you still actively think
about your father when you sing this um
yeah I mean I think about him every day
really so it's like I mean it's like
it's nice to be able to kind of write a
sucks like I kind of avoided writing
about him for many years and then
finally like kind of having a
breakthrough like that was was it just
felt it felt good you know it wasn't
like it wasn't like a negative emotion
so much but it was just kind of like
honoring him
it wasn't morose it was like hey I'm
finally able to sing about you and write
a song about you yeah we celebrate that
this is a great song I'll let you guys
do it
summer has come and passed the innocent
can never last wake me up when September
ends like my father's come to
seven
years as gone so fast wake me up when
September ends
it comes the rain again falling from the
stars drenched in my
again becoming
[Music]
as my memory rests but never forgets
what I lost wake me up when September
ends
[Music]
and
[Applause]
wait
[Music]
three
again
[Music]
summer has come and passed the innocent
can never last
[Music]
that is some [__] riff a [__]